nintendo switch is the home console you
can take on the go you can stay up to
date on all things Nintendo with the
news feature right when you start the
system or wake it from sleep mode
featured articles appear on screen
highlighting the latest updates from
Nintendo you can also find news right
here on the home menu it's your
destination for game news and trailers
behind the scenes info and more when
viewing sales and promotions in the news
section you can click straight through
to Nintendo eShop which is also located
here on the home menu it's your one-stop
shop for browsing buying and downloading
software Nintendo eShop is constantly
updated with new games for every type of
player if you already have a Nintendo
network ID you can merge any funds you
have in that account with your Nintendo
account and use them across all of your
Nintendo systems you can search for
content and apply filters to find just
the right type of game you can even
download games during sleep mode
switch and play Nintendo switch